[Musica]
panta rei secondo l'autorevole rivista
di donna diva moderna è stato tatuaggio
più cool dell'estate 2019 sono lenti lo
russo sono un dottore di ricerca in
chimica fisica e ho fondato una società
che si occupa di vaio tech chimica mi
piace di più dire e vi spiegherò che
cosa c'entra questa scritta in greco con
il mio viaggio nel mondo della chimica
della fisica dell'acqua e del mare
tutto comincia quando mi sono iscritto
all'università
di chimica a roma ed è la prima lezione
che fa uno studente di chimica che
incontra il cosiddetto principio di
conservazione della massa ovvero quello
che il buon eraclito duemila anni prima
aveva già capito nulla si crea nulla si
distrugge tutto si trasforma
l'acqua sia il padre della chimica
aristocratico francese e anche indomito
esattore delle tasse e per questo penso
probabilmente il secondo il terzo
dell'aris della lista di robespierre
decapitato ovviamente
si occupa proprio di questo è qui che
comincia il mio viaggio nel mondo della
chimica perché questo è anche l'inizio
della chimica fisica vai che è
l'attività che mi sono occupato per
circa quattro anni della mia vita a
grenoble una città della francia la
capitale delle alpi francesi come amava
dire una di quelle città praticamente
perfette dove timbrate il biglietto
dell'autobus sopra biglietto
dell'autobus di scrivevano pezzi di
poesie ed è anche il centro della
cosiddetta mezzaluna dell'alta
tecnologia europea quella zona che va da
lione fino a ginevra i fisici sono
tendenzialmente più cool dei chimici
quindi tutti quanti conoscete immagino
ginevra l'acceleratore di particelle ma
anche noi chimici e chimici fisici in
particolare abbiamo i nostri
acceleratori o anche quelle che la
comunicazione del centro dove lavoravo
chiamava sorgente di neutroni al centro
della città perché sembrava un po
maledire centrale nucleare al centro
della città e quindi di che cosa mi sono
occupato in questa sorgente di neutroni
vai mi sono proprio occupato di quello
che è probabilmente la molecola più
semplice che tutti quanti voi conoscete
due elementi tre atomi
41 anomalie quasi quanto le stelle sopra
la bandiera americana e queste numeri e
noi chimici e fisici chiamiamo anomalie
tutto ciò che non riusciamo a spiegare
in parole semplici sono proprio alla
base della vita e quindi ho cominciato
da mare questa complessità in questa
estrema semplicità e mi sono occupato di
perché non mischiare acqua e vino no non
è proprio così mi sono preoccupato che
cosa succede quando si mischia acqua ed
etanolo ovvero il componente principale
del vino è bene non ho trovato
assolutamente la soluzione non ho capito
né io né tutti i miei colleghi che cosa
è veramente succede quello che vi posso
dire è che non esiste la memoria
dell'acqua b
questi fenomeni che avvengono su scala
microscopica sono proprio quelli
responsabili della forma delle proteine
ovvero di quelle grandi molecole che
abbiamo tutti noi esseri viventi che
sono un po come delle macchine
all'interno dei nostri organismi e che
se non avessero quella forma proprio
dovuta a quella anomalia tra l'acqua e
l'etanolo non avrebbero non
esisterebbero e non esisteremmo nemmeno
noi
e allora vai un appassionato di cose
complesse che cosa poteva fare beh io mi
sono fatto un bel anno sabbatico a
marsiglia tra bettole pasti se poi ho
detto adesso
torno in puglia mi apre un'impresa
e ci provo perché vi posso assicurare
che qualche equazione di quanto
meccanica sentivo prima lo masticata
però aprire un'impresa in sud italia e
anche più complesso questo sicuramente
è che cosa poteva fare ma poi cambia che
cosa poteva fare un chimico
beh allora dicevo prima che i fisici
sono sicuramente più cool hanno
inventato la bomba atomica ma nessuno
gli fa una colpa no ai chimici abbiamo
inventato tante cose però spesso ecco mi
ricordo la prima volta che ho parlato
con delle persone del mio progetto era
una riunione di agricoltori biologici e
biodinamici tutti quanti mi hanno detto
che cosa fai io sono un chimico faccio
prodotti per l'agricoltura ho sentito un
attimo un pò di gelo però
fertilizzanti e questo bonsi your fritz
haber premio nobel nel 1908
quando durante il suo speech come si
dice adesso abbiamo creato disse abbiamo
creato panne e dall'area perché lui è
inventato i fertilizzanti e pensate che
da quando li ha inventati lui la
popolazione mondiale è passata da 200
milioni di persone ai 7 miliardi attuali
il sudamerica è uscito dalla povertà
grazie ai fertilizzanti magari non tutti
però sicuramente tanti
certo è anche l'inventore dei gas
nervini talmente tanto appassionato
della mattina della battaglia di pri si
preoccupò insomma di come posizionare
correttamente le bombole ma questi sono
sempre dettagli insomma è
giusto così per fare un attimo lo un
corto vi voglio anche ricordare che la
prima volta che vengono riportato nella
storia dell'umanità l'utilizzo dei
fertilizzanti e proprio nell odissea nel
passo probabilmente io sono a
prescindere di questo questo ted sono un
appassionato
dell'odyssey ma forse nel passo più
bello quando si parla di argo il cane di
ulisse e dorme sullo sterco che verrà
portato nei campi di odisseo questa è la
prima porta che il genere umano
parla di concimi e cosa può fare un
chimico fisico se non
se non occuparsi di quella che non è
l'equazione più tatuata purtroppo la
quanto meccanica vincere sempre di più
quindi vedo moltissime equazioni di
dirac già attuate ma pochi pochi secondi
i principi della termodinamica tatuati
purtroppo il buon einstein diceva che la
termodinamica
l'edificio
intellettuale più inscalfibile del
genere umano
pensate è talmente forte che hanno
scoperto il primo principio il secondo
principio questa è una forma quando non
ne hanno scoperto il terzo siano resi
conto che il terzo andava posto prima
del primo non molliamo rino svenuti
numerati lo hanno chiamato hanno
chiamato principio zero perché sono
talmente tanto forti che non avevano
nemmeno all'afp il coraggio chi l'ha
scoperto lord kelvin
di cambiare i numeri e in questa
equazione c'è scritto una cosa forse
terribile però così come babbo natale
non esiste e il mio compito dirvi una
cosa l'inquinamento
è impossibile da eliminare e scrittori
di tutto in quel simbolino minore o
uguale a zero può essere eliminato
soltanto nei nostri libri nei nostri
quaderni di chimici fisici possiamo
spostare questo sicuramente con grande
facilità o lo possiamo diminuire questo
sì ma mai renderlo 0 ed è proprio qui in
questo punto che mi sono concentrato io
come vai
guardando quelle creature che sono
considerate quegli esseri viventi che
sono considerati almeno nella nostra
cultura perché nella cultura orientale
non è così considerati come qualcosa di
privo di senso inutile le alghe eppure
le alghe per un chimico hanno numerose
sostanze che sono tutte ancora da
scoprire ed è quello che faccio da
quattro anni circa questa parte ovvero
estrarre delle sostanze che permettono
alle piante di assorbire meglio quei
fantastici fertilizzanti chimici che
sono purtroppo anche una delle cause
maggiori le righe in aumento e quindi in
qualche maniera quell'equazione
precedente avvicinarsi sempre di più
allo zero questa e l'innovazione cercare
di portare la tecnologia la conoscenza a
un certo tipo di sostenibilità
ambientale tenendo presente bene i
propri limiti qual è il mio sogno per il
futuro poi cambiare slide se vuoi quello
di
acquisto
scusate non siamo sono stato
ritardatario nel consegnare la
presentazione quindi non c'era il
l'alberino
il già custa diceva una cosa che mi
piace molto ed è particolare che in
questa città già in parte avviene quello
che noi dovremmo guardare il mare non
come i cacciatori non andare e prendere
portare via dal mare ma dovremmo essere
contadini o allevatori pensate che già
nella nostra città da 200 300 anni forse
di più
mi tiri col tori centinaia di persone
ogni giorno si dedicano a questa
attività ed è un'attività a impatto
ambientale negativo e anche le alghe
ovviamente sono piante assorbono co2
assorbono nitrati fosfati vi posso dire
tante altre molecole e le trasformano in
qualcosa di positivo quindi dovremmo
cercare di vedere una soluzione semplice
in un mondo complesso grazie
mi
[Applauso]